este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
culture 2.0 el evento más grande de
youtubers educativos en habla hispana
luego os doy más detalles
te presento a la tribu de los inuits una
de las pocas tribus del mundo que pese a
estar en contacto con occidente han
mantenido casi todas sus tradiciones
vivas y lo primero que debe saber sobre
ellos es que la palabra esquimal es
terriblemente ofensiva para ellos por
eso los llamamos inuits pese a que
groenlandia sea parte de dinamarca los
inuits groenlandeses tienen su propio
idioma sus propias leyes y su propio
gobierno sin embargo en los últimos años
inversores chinos australianos y
canadienses están empezando a llegar al
lugar porque lo habéis adivinado en lo
que respecta a recursos naturales
groenlandia es la nueva áfrica oro gas
zinc uranio y toda clase de minerales
que están por explotar todo esto explica
porque de la noche a la mañana donald
trump esté tan interesado en este
territorio al final de este vídeo
entenderás por qué su apuesta no es tan
descabellada como podría parecer vamos a
verlo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
imagina un pueblo con poco más de 50.000
habitantes pero que tiene las reservas
de petróleo de toda rusia pues bien esta
es la situación actual de groenlandia y
por eso noticias como ésta no son
ninguna tontería
[Música]
no es broma trump realmente quiere
comprar groenlandia lo sé lo sé cuando
hablamos de donald trump es difícil
saber si va en serio o no y desde luego
no lo pone fácil cuando publica tweets
como éste
prometo que no haré esto en groenlandia
sin embargo por extraño que parezca en
esta ocasión tiene todo el sentido del
mundo ya sabéis que trump intenta hacer
todo lo que puede para ganarse un
párrafo bien amplio en los libros de
historia y este es uno de sus mejores
intentos hasta la fecha para empezar ni
siquiera es la primera vez que un
presidente estadounidense intenta
comprar groenlandia sí sí en los años 50
el presidente harry s truman ofreció 200
millones de dólares de la época a la
corona danesa es más tampoco es la
primera vez que eeuu compra tierras a
otros países por ejemplo luisiana
florida y alaska fueron compradas a
francia españa y rusia respectivamente
y finalmente en lo que a recursos
naturales respecta groenlandia es la
tierra prometida de hecho los que seáis
veteranos seguidores de visual político
lo sabéis muy bien porque uno de los
primeros vídeos que publicamos en este
canal ya por el año 2016 está dedicado a
este país por cierto que os diré que ese
es uno de los vídeos que más nos ha
sorprendido porque cuando lo publicamos
pensamos que bueno a quién le iba a
interesar lo que ocurre por groenlandia
pues bien ese vídeo lleva ya más de
500.000 visitas y es que esto es lo que
tenéis vosotros la audiencia de visual
política que tenéis una curiosidad que
de verdad sorprende a veces hasta los
que hacemos el propio canal pero por si
alguna todavía no está del todo
convencido de la oportunidad que supone
groenlandia aquí viene el mejor
argumento la política el estatus
político de groenlandia no está para
nada claro sí vale a estas alturas todos
ya sabréis que pertenecen a la corona de
dinamarca pero cada vez son más
autónomos y hay un enorme movimiento que
busca la independencia de esta región
así que la pregunta que deberíamos
hacernos es cómo se puede comprar un
territorio de verdad groenlandia es una
inversión tan buena como parece y qué
tienen que decir los ciudadanos
groenlandeses los inuit al respecto hoy
vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero
antes antes de continuar apuntados esta
fecha viernes 11 de octubre a las 6 de
la tarde que va a pasar ese día pues
exacto es la fecha del kultur 2.0 el
evento más grande de youtubers de
divulgación en español y dónde va a ser
pues como siempre en la casa encendida
de madrid
ahí vais a poder ver a gigantes de la
divulgación como glóbulo azul alving el
cubil de peter preguntas incómodas y
muchos otros más y ya lo sé ya lo sé que
muchos de vosotros no vivís en españa y
no podéis acudir pues no pasa nada
porque cultura se emite en streaming a
través del link que os voy a dejar en la
descripción así que no tenéis ninguna
excusa para no verlo tranquilitos desde
casa mientras os tomáis hay un café o un
cola cao es más si queréis hasta podéis
hacer preguntas y comentar cosas en
directo en twitter a través de
hasta cultura por ejemplo yo cada vez
que vea que albín se mesa el cabello
hace este gesto que suele hacer yo le
escribiré al mins pero qué pedazo que
tienes hashtag culture y con eso al
vince pues lo va a leer pero os puedo
asegurar que no me pienso perder la
charla de glóbulo azul que es un chico
que habla de medicina y que lo hace de
maravilla o el cubil de peter que es un
historiador como la copa de un pino o
tantos otros youtubers que son
increíbles
así que recordad 11 de octubre viernes a
las 6 de la tarde a la hora española
culture 2.0 la venganza no os lo perdáis
y ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de
historia
imperios a la venta normalmente los
países se expande bien por la conquista
violenta o por la anexión pacífica pero
esta no es la única fórmula nuestra
historia empieza en el año 1803 cuando
el por entonces presidente
estadounidense thomas jefferson compró
un territorio de más de 2 millones de
kilómetros cuadrados a la francia de
napoleón esto es lo que hoy conocemos
como el estado de luisiana a cambio de
15 millones de dólares la joven
república duplicó su tamaño por supuesto
que este tratado fue muy polémico en su
momento pero seamos honestos francia
necesitaba ese dinero más que nadie
napoleón quería conquistar europa y eso
es de todo menos barato y por supuesto
eeuu quería convertirse en un país como
dios manda con un territorio grande y
capaz de hacer acuerdos con otros países
así que el tratado se firmó y ahí es
cuando robert livingston uno de los
firmantes y padres fundadores dijo su
famosa frase
hemos vivido una vida larga pero este es
el trabajo más noble de nuestras vidas
desde hoy eeuu ocupa su lugar entre los
poderes del primer nivel
robert livingston padre fundador pero la
historia no termina aquí veréis el siglo
19 ofreció muchas oportunidades para que
una joven república se expandiera por
aquel entonces el imperio español estaba
al borde de la bancarrota y estaban
demasiado ocupados intentando no perder
sus colonias en américa del sur por otra
parte francia tenía todas sus energías
focalizadas en áfrica habían perdido
todo el interés en norteamérica y
necesitaban dinero así que aquí es
cuando entra a eeuu dispuesta a hacer
negocio la segunda gran compra fue
florida en el año 1819
[Música]
durante mucho tiempo españa había
rechazado las ofertas de washington pero
llegó un momento donde no podían seguir
diciendo que no madrid estaban luchando
para sofocar las revueltas de
independencia en américa central y
sudamérica acababan de salir de una
guerra con francia y el dinero que
ofrecían los estadounidenses no venían
nada mal
así es como españa no le quedó más
remedio que vender florida y que
consiguió eeuu con esto fuese extender
su territorio desde el mississippi hasta
el océano atlántico a partir de ese
momento washington continuó haciendo
tratados de todo tipo para adquirir
nuevos territorios de otros estados pero
sin duda alguna la compra más grande de
todas fue la de alaska el estado más
grande de la unión se lo compraron a
rusia por 7,2 millones de dólares en el
año 1867
[Música]
[Aplausos]
por aquel entonces el zar alejandro
segundo estaba encantado de vender el
territorio porque era incapaz de
defenderlo en caso de guerra y este
acuerdo le vino de perlas a eeuu sí es
cierto al ashkar un territorio
prácticamente despoblado pero tenían oro
a punta pala así que miles de
estadounidenses se marcharon a vivir el
sueño americano y pronto surgieron
ciudades como por ejemplo klondike
alimentadas por la fiebre del oro para
el año 1959 alaska se convirtió en un
estado como tal y en 2016 suponía el 15
por ciento del pib de todo el país
porque creo que ya os lo podéis imaginar
por el petróleo en este momento alaska
es uno de los cinco estados productores
de crudo y en 2017 batieron su récord de
producción algo parecido ocurre con el
gas así que si por raro que suene
comprar este territorio rusia fue una
gran inversión
[Aplausos]
pero ya sé lo que me vais a decir ahora
a ver fonseca a todas estas compras se
hicieron con monarquías absolutas o
imperios coloniales es decir que la
gente que vivía en estos territorios no
tenían ni voz ni voto pero ahora las
cosas han cambiado los groenlandeses
tienen mucho que decir sobre si quieres
ser un estado de eeuu o si quieren
seguir formando parte de la corona de
dinamarca verdad además de verdad es una
oportunidad de negocio tan buena como
parece pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
posiblemente el país más rico del mundo
pese a todo ese tesoro que tiene los
groenlandeses bajo sus pies la industria
más importante de groenlandia en este
momento no es el petróleo sino la pesca
hablamos del 90 por ciento de las
exportaciones de este país para que os
hagáis una idea más de la tercera parte
de todos esos 56 mil groenlandeses vive
de una forma u otra del gobierno
piense como funcionarios o trabajando en
empresas subvencionadas para que os
hagáis una idea en la capital de esta
región o de esta isla
que tiene algo más de 16.000 habitantes
hay un centro comercial pues bien ese
centro comercial está pagado con dinero
del gobierno danés todos los años
dinamarca se gasta alrededor de 530
millones de dólares en transferencias a
groenlandia eso es más de nueve mil
dólares por habitante y todos los años y
lo cierto es que después de gastarse
todo ese dinero copenhague recibe
bastante poco pero sin embargo las cosas
están empezando a cambiar
[Música]
al principio muchas mineras australianas
y chinas pusieron sus ojos en esta isla
y ahí es cuando europa se dio cuenta de
que tenían que hacer algo para sacarle
el partido a groenlandia
necesitamos asociaciones innovadoras con
otros países con respecto a las materias
primas las empresas están presionando a
la comisión para esto lo necesitan para
sobrevivir
europa no es tan rica en materias primas
y necesitamos hacerlo mejor
antonio tajani comisario europeo de
industria en 2012 y la pregunta es por
qué quiero decir teniendo tantísimo
petróleo y minerales porque no explotan
toda esa riqueza es por una cuestión de
ecología se pegaba ahora en serio pues
sí por supuesto a todo el mundo le
gustaría explotar todos esos recursos
naturales
el problema pues que ya me diréis como
perforamos la capa de hielo hablamos de
un manto que en algunas zonas puede
tener hasta un kilómetro de grosor y
aunque el cambio climático puede poner
las cosas un poco más fáciles también
genera muchísimos problemas
por ejemplo todo ese zumo de dinosaurio
del que hablábamos antes está en la
costa groenlandesa y la costa
groenlandesa no son playas paradisíacas
cubiertas de nieve sino acantilados os
acordáis de hélice verde el titán y pues
bien es muy probable que ese iceberg
viniera de groenlandia este es el origen
de casi todos los iceberg del atlántico
y si ya sé que en latinoamérica muchos
decir icebergs en lugar de iceberg pero
toda la vida en españa
he oído iceberg y también está bien
dicho lo cierto es que da igual como lo
llamemos icebergs o iceberg son bloques
de hielo del tamaño de un rascacielos y
que se desgarran de la superficie en
cuestión de minutos creedme no os
gustaría estar trabajando en una
plataforma de petrolero al lado de un
sitio donde caen iceberg y cuanto más se
deshace la capa del hielo
más riesgo de iceberg vamos a tener
[Música]
pero vamos a suponer que hemos
conseguido superar todos esos obstáculos
pues bien todavía tendríamos un problema
más la falta de infraestructura por
ejemplo en la zona norte de esta isla
hay una mina de zinc que se va a empezar
a explotar por una empresa australiana
pues bien cuando sea que terminen la
construcción de las instalaciones es
posible que se convierta en la mayor
mina de zinc del mundo pero la distancia
que va desde esta mina hasta la capital
de groenlandia no es tan larga como la
que hay desde gibraltar hasta el centro
de noruega y no hay ni carreteras ni
ferrocarriles ni nada que se le parezca
para conectar estos dos puntos y por
cierto recordad que la parte central de
la isla es inhabitable de hecho sólo el
3 por ciento de la superficie de
groenlandia puede ser habitable por el
ser humano y todo esto explica por qué
esos 56 mil groenlandeses esos 56 mil y
nuits están concentrados en unos pocos
pueblecitos y si por supuesto que la
mina puede ser rentable si no lo fuera
esta empresa australiana que por cierto
se llama iron bar que no se habría
gastado 500 millones de dólares en la
obra pero hablamos de inversiones
millonarias que no siempre van a ser tan
rentables y todo esto está en el lado de
la economía pero ahora vamos a ver la
política porque aunque mejoras en la
tecnología y groenlandia pudiera
construir toda la frase
que necesita trump seguiría teniendo que
convencerles de que se dejarán comprar y
os preguntaréis hasta qué punto es fácil
que esto ocurra pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
una relación complicada groenlandia es
parte del reino de dinamarca desde el
año 1814 sin embargo han sido capaces de
mantener casi todas sus leyes y
costumbres y wii y os preguntaréis cómo
es esto posible cómo es posible que en
dinamarca siendo uno de los países más
modernos del mundo tengan una región
donde ni siquiera existe el concepto de
propiedad privada como lo entendemos hoy
en día y ojo que esto no es todo porque
si pensabais que proveen la cndh ya era
algo así como un paraíso natural sobre
hielo estáis muy equivocados
hablamos de una zona con altísimas tasas
de alcoholismo criminalidad y violencia
de género lo cierto es que aunque
pertenezcan al reino de dinamarca desde
el año 1814 los groenlandeses no han
dejado de luchar por tener más autonomía
en el año 1974 fueron declarados una
región autónoma y en 2009 se volvieron
aún más independientes cuando el 70% de
la población votó a favor de la ley de
autogobierno
[Música]
ahora mismo el danés no es ni siquiera
la lengua oficial de groenlandia el
gobierno está promoviendo la lengua
calisur en las escuelas groenlandia
también tiene su parlamento local en
otras palabras que la única relación
política que tiene en dinamarca con los
groenlandeses son los escaños que tienen
reservados los inuit en el parlamento de
copenhague y por supuesto también está
el dinero porque durante estos 200 años
dinamarca ha estado transfiriendo dinero
a groenlandia sin apenas recibir nada a
cambio así que a partir de los años 50
copenhague trató de convertir esta
región en una economía moderna y así es
como se construyeron las casas de nube
que si las miráis veréis que son iguales
a las de cualquier pueblo danés y por
eso si viajáis este lugar efectivamente
encontrareis todas las comodidades de
occidente
sin embargo la esperanza de vida es diez
años más baja que la de dinamarca tienen
altísimos niveles de desempleo y la tasa
de suicidios más alta del planeta tierra
a todo esto hay que añadirle el choque
cultural entre los inuits y los daneses
y entendemos por qué los groenlandeses
quieren estar a su aire y ser
independientes para que os hagáis una
idea el partido nacionalista groenlandés
es una de las principales fuerzas del
parlamento y el 67% de la población está
a favor de la soberanía
todavía creo que groenlandia alcanzará
la independencia durante el tiempo en el
que sigo activo en política al heca
jamont ex primera ministra gro en
landesa pero como os podéis imaginar
dinamarca quiere mantener el control de
la isla a fin de cuentas después de
décadas pagando subvenciones ahora es
cuando pueden sacar algo de partido a
todo este terreno
[Música]
groenlandia el país que quiere ganar
dinero con el cambio climático
las altas temperaturas amenazan el
estilo de vida tradicional de
groenlandia pero mientras el hielo
retrocede nuevas oportunidades de
minería pesca y turismo están ayudando a
las comunidades a adaptarse a medida que
el ártico se deshiela los recursos de
groenlandia son más accesibles y de
verdad que si pensabais que estos
líderes nacionalistas groenlandeses tan
respetuosos con sus tradiciones inuit
son una especie de yo que sé
pocahontas moderna o se equivoca vice
los grandes somos muy buenos a la hora
de descubrir nuevas oportunidades no
queremos ser victimizados por el cambio
climático yo soy optimista veo más
opciones positivas que negativas para el
país ojalá esto no estuviera ocurriendo
pero la realidad es la que es una vez
está aquí tienes la obligación de sacar
lo mejor de ello al heca jamón ex
primera ministra de groenlandia para que
os hagáis una idea en el año 2013
groenlandia dio marcha atrás a todas las
restricciones que había en minería del
uranio así que otra empresa australiana
en este caso green and minerals ya está
montando una planta de extracción de
uranio y tierras raras en otra ciudad de
la costa sur que se llama marsac y no
pensáis que sólo hablamos de materias
primas lo hemos dicho mil veces en
visual político cuidado con las rutas
árticas porque pueden ser una
oportunidad increíble para muchos países
en el año 2007 muchos pasajes se
descongelaron y ahora ya hay rutas
comerciales que permiten saltarse el
canal de panamá y el canal de suez
esto implica menos tiempo menos dinero y
menos riesgos de pirata
así que es fácil entender por que trump
está tan interesado en groenlandia y
porque dinamarca no quiere vendérselo ni
en sueños
[Música]
rehn land ya no está a la venta
groenlandia no es danesa groenlandia
pertenece a los groenlandeses creo
firmemente que no hay que tomarse esto
en serio med frederiksen primer ministro
danés lo que no está tan claro es si los
groenlandeses quieren seguir siendo
parte de dinamarca o no o si en lugar de
ser independientes no les importaría
convertirse en el estado número 53 de la
unión
vale vale quería decir el estado 51 de
la unión así que la cuestión ahora es
para vosotros queréis que los
groenlandeses estarían dispuestos a
venderse a eeuu y al señor donald trump
creéis que seguirán intentando ser
independientes llegará un momento en el
que este país encontrará el modo de
sacarle partido a todos esos recursos
naturales
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
político y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo también
y nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto